je m'appelle Scarlett Marlowe et je suis
étudiante en archéologie urbaine 370 pieds
sous ce point est une chambre cachée
qui pourrait contenir une pièce manquante critique
de notre histoire comment sommes-nous
censés descendre des catacombes
il y a 200 miles de tunnels juste
sous nos pieds  tenant les restes
de six millions de cadavres encore c'est l'
Empire
ce sont des ossements humains Luther ici c'est
bon
lent et régulier ouais je pense que je suis coincé
respirer qu'est-ce que c'était qu'est-ce
qu'on fait maintenant hein
on ne peut pas revenir en arrière tu devrais juste  continue d'
avancer dis moi qu'on n'est pas juste allé en
cercle c'est exactement pareil non
tout est à l'envers ce qui est arrivé
à l'entrée attends il y a quelque chose
ici
oh mon
dieu qu'est ce que c'est quand j'étais gamin
on avait un piano qui avait l'air  exactement comme
ça, j'avais l'habitude de le jouer tout le temps que la
touche a4 était foirée
allez pouvez-vous lire cela entrer dans la
mythologie qui est une inscription sur le
cas d'aide et ils devraient être obligés de
ramper sur leur ventre et le royaume
o  f ténèbres applaudir que quelqu'un là-bas